et l'on retrouve notre correspondant à
Kiev Gulliver Craig bonjour Gulliver les
causes de ce crash n'ont pas été
dévoilés quels sont les pistes évoquées
sur place
alors comment on l'a entendu les
autorités ukrainiennes mettent en garde
contre toutes spéculation quand aux
causes de ce crash mais c'est bien une
enquête criminelle qui a été ouverte par
le procureur général et ils disent tout
en restant ouvert à toutes les
hypothèses possibles privilégiez trois
pistes principales soit que le pilote
soit en faute de quelques manières soit
un problème technique avec l'hélicoptère
ou bien le sabotage quand on pense au
sabotage on pense bien sûr au fait que
l'Ukraine est en guerre contre la Russie
même si les Russes n'ont pas été nommés
quand les enquêteurs ont évoqué ces
pistes possibles il convient peut-être
de retenir que le poste de ministre de
l'Intérieur est un poste très puissant
très important dans le gouvernement
ukrainien d'autant plus en ce moment
puisque les forces de la garde nationale
dépendent non pas côté du ministère de
la défense mais bien du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc le ministère de
l'Intérieur est absolument impliqué dans
l'effort de la guerre contre la Russie
et justement on sait que c'était
hélicoptère se rendait près de la ligne
de front dans la région de harkis dans
le nord-est du pays merci pour ces
précisions Gulliver crack en direct de
Kiev est toujours concernant l'Ukraine
on attend